- I knew when I said goodbye
to him that it wasn't goodbye
forever and I'd see him again
and when I see him again
he won't be in pain anymore.
And he won't be weak.
(slow music)
- I was six years old
when my mom passed away.
- My mom died when I was 17, she was sick.
She had cancer the
majority of my childhood.
- My dad was sick for as
long as I can remember.
When I was born he was
just recently diagnosed
with multiple sclerosis.
- You know, I went and
talked to my mom and I,
you know, I sat down next
to her bed and I told her,
I said, "This is what the
doctors have told us."
They said there might be a
solution, but we might have to,
you know, go across the
country to this doctor's place
to try it out.
And she just looked at me
and she's like, "No more."
I can't.
- My father who was young and didn't smoke
came down with pancreatic
cancer and within less than
six months he had passed away.
- My father died first.
He had arterial sclerotic
heart disease so he had a
massive heart attack.
And then my mother, she
died about five months later
and just had, like, a sudden
cardiac arrest and I was
on the phone with her when it
happened, but I didn't know
that she had died.
- We always had this thing
in our family when you,
you know, love you, love you more.
I believe it was me to him, "Love ya."
And then on my way out the
door I heard, "Love you more."
And that was the last
thing he ever said to me.
- And he was throwing up
due to the chemo therapy.
I was young and I walked past
it and I recoiled and said
gross and ran away.
Ever since then, that's
just replayed in my head
since childhood.
- There were so many unknowns happening.
Like, I felt that it was
my fault, then I realized
it wasn't my fault.
- I remember walking
out of the funeral home
holding the casket and I
grabbed my little brother
and I hugged him, I said,
"I promise you everything's
"gonna be okay, I'm gonna make sure of it.
"Everything's gonna be fine."
And I hope I did the right thing.
I'm hoping that I was able
to do what, at least half
my mother was able to do for me.
- It was mother's day
and everyone was, like,
crocheting these things for
their mom and I was the only
kid in class that, like, didn't.
So then I just did it for my
grandma which sounds weird.
So, yeah, that's when
I kind of understood that, like,
that everyone else kind of
had this thing and I didn't.
- You never really lose certain
memories or certain parts
of their personality and I,
to this day, will be watching
a movie that I watched with
him several times or a TV show
that I watched several times
with him and I can still hear
the parts where he laughed.
- That void is always gonna
be there and it's a part of
who I am today, but it
doesn't have to pull me in,
it doesn't have to take over me.
And it's something that
I work on all the time.
- I had a therapist for the
first six months after it
happened 'cause it helps to
talk to someone without bias.
- I go to therapy.
Yeah, I go to therapy because
this isn't an issue that's
just gonna, like, go away.
You are going to deal with
the loss of your parents
for years.
- If there's somebody that you care about,
you need to let them know.
And just don't waste time
'cause the biggest things
you learn because you can
be taken today, tomorrow,
in 50 years, you don't know.
- I learned a lot in those
16 years and I, like,
cherish those memories.
- I always tell my friends,
you know, cherish your parents.
You never know when they're gonna go.
- Cherish the time you had
with them and share that
with people because everyone's
in it together and we all
are going through the same thing.
We are in a struggle together
and together we are stronger.